okay it's time everybody episode 2 is
out it kind of feels more real somehow
now that we know for sure this is it I
mean it was called the final episode but
now we know they ain't coming back boy I
can't click on it this is great
Oh what no just click on it what is
happening oh I think they're good you're
watching the light right let's play this
there's no G to watching yes for a long
time for some place we could call home
just when we thought we'd found a huge
stash of food it turned out to be a trap
that could have been the end
but I woke up and found I've been saved
by a guy named Marlin living inside an
old boarding school it felt like a
chance at having a home a real one we
had to go back to the train station to
see if any food survived the explosion
but someone else had the same idea I
didn't want to risk it so I let him take
some of the food and leave I found
Marlin and Brody in the basement that
night arguing about the man we'd seen
and I learned why Brody was yeah
everything just went to thank you
the man was brave of raiders they'd run
into a year ago Marlin traded
Tennessee's older sisters to the Raiders
to keep himself safe
he attacked Brody and locked me in the
basement with her and she turned I had
to stop her
Marland stole a G's gun and tried to
convince them I had murdered Brodie not
cool that was really me
violet backed me up with everyone
against him remember I went out of
marlin I told him he could stay but he
couldn't be our leader but then it
didn't matter like hotel games and AJ
pulled the trigger he remembered what I
taught him how he remembered huh do you
know my name for the head a rat a rat
Arang
let's keep going with episode 2 so
apparently they made a statement where
they said basically we're gonna try
we're gonna try to finish three and four
I sure hope they they do it would be cuz
they went L quit they announced that
they there were a lot of inside rumors
that they weren't gonna make episode
three and four but now they're saying
we're gonna try at least
so we'll see I'll keep you guys updated
oh my god the ice looks so weird I'm not
used to them yet
I made you some coffee
it was in the kitchen tin said I can
have some I didn't still it still ate
I'm surprised you remember how to make
it we haven't had a coffee in a long
time you put it in hot water you're
right
Thanks last night with Marlin I heard
Lou listen and what he called me what
did he call you am i a murderer oh oh I
mean yeah you are hey you did know you
did kill him oh my god
from the nurse's office mr.
blew his brains out you shot him he's
dead here alone Adam Smith
you promised Marlon you said you'd help
him fix things what the [ __ ] did you
teach this kid Lewis called me a
murderer but but we're supposed to kill
bad stuff monsters did I do it bad yes
I thought Marlon was bad he killed Brody
he he kept telling lies
oh my god I don't know I don't know what
the house tell me I'm trying but the
gang just I should know only quiet was
good so that I can try not to be your it
was kind of marked here yeah you kind of
killed right sometimes people do bad
things like Marlon did but when you shot
him he wasn't a threat to us anymore if
you kill someone when they're no longer
threatening you that's murder even if
they were bad even then it was wrong
what are we gonna do you live in your
line it's not like you killed somebody
Oh Oh No release hey it has changed now
back off all of you
you talk smiling down and then they
[ __ ] murdered him
take AJ go inside let's go
oh just let them go back to the dorms
what happens the next time one of us
does something this kid doesn't like
should we expect to pull it - that's not
what happens
it's exactly what happened Marlin
started this he killed Brody and almost
got me - AJ did what he had to do what
he had to he didn't have to shoot Marlin
in the [ __ ] skull yeah over just back
off okay back off
seriously I'm actually on his side
that's kind of weird
let's go if I'm a murderer am I gonna
die - all right no well I think
murderers are like monsters and oh I
know what happens to monsters nothing
good nothing good at all we can forgive
them murders even some monsters they get
a second chance some monsters not all
when bad people like murderers try to
make it right
that's when other people forgive them
that sounds hard it is we're going to
fix this you and me I'm going to help
you a tone a tone it means make up for
what you did wrong we'll make it all
right with the others let's make them
copy no we save you from that car wreck
and you [ __ ] murder to get back Mitch
get back
oh you're gonna let him kill me - then
who's next
sim really haven't enough people died
tonight
Brody Marlon we can't keep killing each
other
[ __ ] are you saying that to me after
what he did
make sure we'll remember that William
edge huh
well you hey what is it
I can't believe they're saying you've
killed a lot of people you murdered your
friend Lee didn't you what I said he was
handcuffed he was eggs so that means you
murdered him AJ don't make me slap you
how do they ask me that what you did is
completely different I'm sorry I wasn't
trying to make you mad at all yeah what
I had to do it I said I'm sorry I had to
oh okay yeah look you made you made her
sad AJ are you happy now Clinton to walk
you back
Oh
too many emotions up and down I can't
handle this what is this hey violet said
to come get you for the funeral oh
really
we used to have them more then we
stopped it seems right though I brought
you something for me I figured you'd be
afraid with everyone all upset but you
were brave last night like a firefighter
no fire Freddy's are good I'm a murderer
yeah no you're not you gotta have a
trial first they decided that stuff in a
courtroom that's how it works
worked before back then it was about
who's innocent who's guilty okay find us
the courthouse what's that that's where
the trials happen you appear before a
judge there are no more judges I guess
you're right shado my fire mayor you
should keep him cuz you're good I like
him but maybe we could play with him
later together sure after the funeral
they buried them already if I all
started soon see you out there I mean I
would balance this is way too awkward
they killed him this is gonna be hard
everyone's going to be upset we need to
show them we care okay oh I'm gonna be
so super pissed that we kill the guy so
like let's just make a really good
impression
I like how they're still giving me
controls play through three seasons but
don't know how to move all right let's
head together do you think his is better
no I like them both I'm giving very few
reasons to like AJ he's getting a really
heart that all I got to talk to him
again I already talked to AJ let's go
ready yeah don't bring your gun AJ you
know they bounce
anytime anything bad happen in these in
these games baby this is the Iowa State
now see we already know it's really bad
here
and sons as harsh as the Texas all right
hey how did you get there
AJ what you doing there buddy
oh now you're sad I did that
come on man I guess he's also a kid like
how much can you put on a child and not
yourself Clementine is the one that
raised and that dog is terrifying
what about the girl oh oh yeah oh oh god
they're here so what they knew Brody
didn't they yeah but Marlin just leave
them alone [ __ ]
Clem what why do people have funerals oh
my god you need to soon said they used
to have them more they died but I don't
get it
well just say goodbye to someone you've
lost but they're dead
this is your last chance to see them
before they're gone forever
I made them all sad like if someone took
you away yeah does everyone get a
funeral people do some animals - she's
even lobsters
even monsters
ten you ready
Browdy
you always said you wanted to go to the
beach so I drew it for you no Marlin was
I can't not for Marlin after what he did
to the twins and Brodie you didn't even
like Brodie you always mean I can't
someone else do it [ __ ] dude don't
seriously Louis he was your best friend
it wasn't perfect but he deserved better
than to get gunned down by a kid he
killed him like it was nothing we all
saw it and no one stopped him I don't
appreciate your tone Mitch yeah I don't
well I don't appreciate your kid
murdering my friend I know I'm a
murderer but I'm gonna tone yeah
that's holy [ __ ] I can't listen to this
yeah
what I did was bad and I'm gonna make it
up to you I promise you don't have to
make up [ __ ] Marlon was a [ __ ]
murderer and a liar and if we all ask
more questions about Minnie and Sophie
disappearing last year none of this
would have happened
she's got a bent Janice was it Marlins
fault then whose fault was it
pilots right you all share a
responsibility for what happened to
Sophie and Minnie oh okay yeah Marlon
who's responsible for that
that's Marlon that's money no see what I
mean how can any of us trust these
[ __ ] people what are you saying I'm
saying they got a [ __ ] go take a boat
Jordie decides they stay or they leave
today
that does seem fair are you serious it's
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] I don't want to
leave you all decide we should we'll go
Klum he's very pretty fan votes the only
way to settle this so we'll be arguing
forever fine
I guess we're [ __ ] voting right we
need a trial Lewis needs to vote could
you go get him and try to talk to him
come on Rosie come here girl oh hey
would you do that you guys go wait I'll
come get you no I don't care
[ __ ] Wow please don't kick us out
come on let's go
oh my gosh what's the big deal we could
just go anyway you know after something
big like this I really feel like it's
better to just start over break your toe
or something come here sit down
no it didn't work I did what you said
and they didn't even care I know that I
was bad but but they don't know let me
fix it
AJ breathe remember what we do when
we're mad do you what do we do when
we're mad you stop and think and I'm
still really really mad I know that I'm
not supposed to get mad or sad and you
have every reason to be upset we'll deal
with it together okay okay we stop we
think and we breathe breathe
feel better you're still mad huh
and I think upside to AJ please who
would have thought giving a kid a gun
was a bad idea i I don't know me I did
what you told me to I know you're a good
listener I wanted to make them all feel
better it didn't work watch tell me to
do that if it didn't work they wouldn't
listen we don't know that it didn't work
they might have voted for us to stay I
don't know oh Jesus
violet was on our side maybe she'll
persuade the others yeah maybe I don't
want to go we can J hey listen I know
you don't get the fish I like knowing
where we are all the time
to bed the food you've been here one day
I like the two nights not all of them
but tin and Lewis and violet if there's
ever a problem you can just pull the gun
we took the vote you have to leave don't
we get to vote I vote that we stay seems
fair that's not how it works maybe it
should be you don't have to like it
good cuz I don't fine
I get it we'll learn to live with your
decisions
somehow seriously that's it I mean yeah
and you're not gonna fight it at all
what's the point you've already decided
yes we have
so [ __ ] stupid you said you'd go
along with it if we voted fairly it's
[ __ ] and you'd know it if you
weren't so used to burying your head in
the sand
oh I'm burying my head in the sand hey
Marlon all you want but you can't tell
me AJ's and dangerous too I mean I
wouldn't feel safe with that kid around
we'll wait for you to pack up then Luis
and I will escort you out past a safe
zone
we'll make sure you get to the road
safely
it's not a lot but at least you won't
die on the way we could have happily
dumped you outside the gates thanks for
making sure that we know don't thank
them it's it's their fault we gotta
leave they're gonna get rid of us get
him under control
AJ breathe where's Tim
I gotta say goodbye
he was really upset about the vote and
he's not talking to anybody it's best to
leave him alone when he's like this but
for the record he wanted you to stay for
the record wait does AJ still have that
gun
hand it over is this necessary
hell yes it's necessary it's yours AJ
you should keep it but I murdered Marlon
with it yeah but you'll need protection
outside fine let the kid keep the murder
weapon tip I wonder if that will make
any difference now we won't Felix don't
you ever learn sorry
surprise AJ learn how to draw at all I
mean right
what do you guys think should they have
seen as it's very pretty
you know when they up the ambience the
zombie time maybe the guy from the woods
will attack now or something well we get
another car
probably not you got lucky before
someone walking my shoes are gonna break
well we'll have to hope they hold out
you're not gonna believe again well tear
up a shirt and tie them up if we have to
it's not so bad yeah that was before
yeah yeah we happily pretty good at it
by now almost like going home for you
guys yeah and it almost killed us
you saw how [ __ ] up we were after that
car crash I swear Oh
we're here the roads that way anything
you want to say before we go I've said
plenty thanks for trying to keep us
you're welcome
I wish you could stay I don't want this
come on let's just go give us a minute
what do you yeah so do I I wish we
hadn't [ __ ] it up
you didn't Marlon did even dead he's
still ruining [ __ ]
Jesus violet give him some [ __ ] peace
just stay safe both of you
there look like go got that guy out any
minute just try to be more careful with
it okay
I will shoots him
No
let's get going
the Sun will set soon how do you know I
don't know I can just feel it how by the
orange light this may be cold that
settles on my skin it happens right
before a storm - I don't feel that hmm
you haven't been on the road as long as
me
Klim hmm well would be okay I thought we
were done running from all the bad
people
now of course we'll be okay we're used
to this I hate it out here I wish we
could go back yeah so do I go Jeff
bladder oh my god that scared me who
shot me and what what happened
Hey look now come on out wonder holiday
you on the road how long do you think
you can hide [ __ ] that's the man from
the train station yes scared
one weird the receding hairline
stay here aim your mouths okay let's see
you where should aim here okay all right
let's see if I can do this okay
hey what yeah I did it
shoot him AJ shift and he Wow really
changing it up what the heck
tough what's [ __ ] aren't you finish him
can I actually oh look you can't m14
gang
oh why me no AJ the gun now the time to
murder a wooden boy any closer your
friend might get her head blown off who
runs towards someone with a gun you just
shoot the gun you idiot
good to see you again squirt don't I
seen these ones before fighters both of
them you'll like him we're looking for a
kid runs a community near here Marlon
he's dead [ __ ] this can still work how
about it you want to take us back to
your school help us talk to your friends
it's not like you have many other
options it's not my school I don't live
there I find that very hard to believe
not a lot of kid communes around here
let him go please sure if you do like we
ask otherwise I'm happy to crack his
head open
you ever seen old fruit explode after
you throw it at something that's just
how it'll look
just like Clementine hey sorry
it's her oh my god I'm in time it's you
hi my name is Lily you see the one from
there no wait what you probably don't
remember me I think I recognize her Lily
I thought you died I see I don't even I
barely remember the hell not now
[ __ ] is this
from season two right Lee isn't with you
oh wow sorry sorry I got a Google you
know what we shouldn't just kick you out
we should hear what everybody know is
that Lilly is that the Lilly no [ __ ]
don't you let's go no no freakin way
the fact that someone died everyone
ignores the fact that someone died is
that Lilly will return how two percent
confirmed well you confirm it buddy
it's the same it's the same concept as
well she's a murderer she's shot at a
random ah that's pretty clever I like it
he's dead dead is that really her she
looks so different she looks so
different like Lilly looked kind of
pretty like she was one of the I mean
it's kind of weird for me to say I mean
come on I mean you know what I mean
that is her holy cow do you guys
remember I thought I could use her from
someone else's season too
man that's crazy and I was complaining
like they made him keep anyway I'll
never forget him leaving me on the side
of the road to die I don't blame him
I was clearly a threat to the group
after I shot that girl
harlot it's funny yeah you shot Carl
should have left you behind - might have
lived longer if he did same thing will
happen to you if you repeat his mistakes
your little boy there and died
protecting him
you may be able to keep this up a while
longer but eventually he'll slow you
down I don't think so
AJ knows how to handle himself he's got
spirit I'll give you that but you and I
know that won't be enough we don't have
time for all this we've got history
great you know where I know our point is
we got a job to do we can help you raise
that boy Clementine but we need you to
do something for us what helped you
kidnap a couple more kids we don't need
a couple we need all of it
we'll take you back to the Delta to join
our people we have walls we have working
solar panels and we grow our own food
pretty nice to go back to your friends
and convince them to come peacefully no
one will be harmed
I'm hot Marlon here's what I'll do I'll
take the little squirt you like now that
way I'm sure you'll play nice be smart
about this Clementine gave us or them
kind of world Clem if you want to save
your little one you won't pick that bye
Lilly you should have died long ago yeah
Oh
come on
sweet use your gun
AJ okay really a quick time wish button
will like click Next
it's a super game ha shoot it
cinnamon Daleks m14 and Olympia
we're screwed i skew again
bummer
[Music]
oh hey baby again
Klim what is it
no what happened you fell on the night
oh he's shot
look at it
look at it look at it that's right
sit down eight I mean look it's a tiny
one it's a tiny one what is wrong with
this oh it's good
see we're hanging like a Halloween mask
you just have to look at really old and
gross and they'll be like yeah you're
with us I like your style man
yeah
even if they haven't made episode three
in four yeah it just hit me like surely
the script must have already been done
man this is getting actually really good
finally some interesting stuff I like it
where's that man where's that Sam be
wisely so night I thought zombies eat
you
oh the shine allow me I'll keep him
still
[Music]
how big Yanks I don't want this that's
like a little pimples this just cause
more baby look they're not even in there
like hovering above it's some nice ASMR
stuff I like it not to be loud
that's okay AJ just breathe put your
hands there stop the bleeding oh hey AJ
is just gonna pack you up it's enough
for now
you know for being survivors they easy
easy and where's her stuff my gun lost
it buddy
oh let's got shot I saw they saved us
yeah they did you got shot in the arm
he'll be ok this sucks
that's a bad day it's a really bad day
oh no don't turn on these
who is this guy oh sorry I'm eating
you know when we you endanger you the
walkers were sent to help you he
controls the walkers was part of a group
call themselves whispers they've learned
to live in herds among walkers move
among them sometimes guide them he said
was right
why are you alone if you were part of a
group they attacked a community saw the
carnage didn't want to be part of it so
they control the herd that's interesting
holy Doody he's got a vault eat both of
you thank you
where you cut it seems you have a name
been a while this is a resume I've said
it Oh another familiar character perhaps
is it Lily again no James why did you
help us James
not people who attacked you what do you
know about them I know they steal kids
they took - last year a common practice
for them they're at war
up north their entire community against
another it's why they take people to
make them fight train them use them you
would join their war we've already been
through that champ type of chapter yes
that's why I helped you thank you thank
you
looks sorry are you copying me now Wow
then he can talk to him hey they say
make chief throwing distractor works
just as well and nobody gets hurt
no it s not him
[Music]
I mean yeah they seem pretty so yeah so
he looks at them differently huh safe
my god you almost difficult to send the
hurt in to save you I didn't want them
to die and what is this they're already
dead
oh my I'm oh come on man so James do you
just hang around in the woods saving
random people after I left my group I
wandered first time alone never saw war
everywhere first against walkers then
against each other I hoped it would be
better here
where are you from here or somewhere far
away
Georgia long way from home it feels like
forever ago yeah it was I want to see
how the city's developed at this point
so where are you from Washington the
city or the state the city dad ran a
food truck
I helped you've got a fever his wound
will need proper cleaning and medicine
if you're lucky enough to have any the
school has medicine but I don't think
they'll share it yeah well yeah that's
why those people attacked you isn't it
to get to that school they'll destroy
whatever they find
bring more guns more fighters take
everyone inside they won't be able to
fight them off
sorry I'm we wanted to say this forever
now why don't they have backpacks okay
they're supposed to be survivors you
have to go back but you'll lose them how
I bit my tongue yeah I'll go back
convince them to help AJ they'll take us
back once they see him they wouldn't
turn AJ away you hope I'll help you get
back past the walkers a few more hours
and we'll go that's a few hours for you
to sleep I'm trying to better
AJ I'll stay awake you don't have to
sleep I'll keep watch okay I will
what about you don't need it
not tonight rest well in the rain night
his hairs got to be solved that's a good
pillow good night
I want to know more about the whispering
community because that seems like the
obvious choice isn't it you can just
they won't attack you right as long as
you wear a zombie max seems like a
surefire way to just guess he liked by
random people yeah he's so hot I can
carry him you're exhausted
no max made out of actual human if it
looks really gross I think it is
watch out for the traps we're almost
there violet Louis they came back look
he live out there Ilana right you are
gonna enjoy the zombie Lane
I kind of like it now you just kill
zombies whenever you want not ready
thanks James
what's happening I can't keep carrying
you I'll be inside soon breasts now
[ __ ] is he he's alive
he was shot he's got a fever come on
let's get him inside I can't
it's all he would be fine
it's okay buddy I got you
[Music]
I like this episode so far it's a lot
better than the first one let me see I
have what I need upstairs come on I
thought we needed to convince them we
got the shrapnel out of him we it's a
long story
this zombie was like super smart it was
really here
he's running a fever body's trying to
fight infection poor little guy
Ruby and Lewis will take care of him you
come with me we can talk in the office
Clem Shh
you just try to rest okay we're gonna
fix you right up
so AJ listen to Ruby okay she'll look
after you come on what do we do when
we're scared when fear starts to get the
upper hand we tell it if we push it we
don't let it take over I'm good no
Ray J now I feel bad
Clementine please We Need to Talk
[Music]
what happened out in the woods I saw
they had you pinned tonight yeah I got
so crazy when I heard you call for help
I didn't even think I just let go over
the arrow I wasn't even sure if I'd hit
her and then Lois got shot six six
inches over would be digging another
grave yeah I really thought you were
dead Clem it's really good to see you
again it's good to see you too
just wish Mitch and the others felt the
same Lois and I told them what happened
in the woods that woman who attacked you
Lily say you do know her we were
wondering yeah who the hell is she I
mean I know you're not like with her
group but the others I don't like the
coincidence Hersh going up right after
you I mean lily and I were friends a
long time ago friends back when the
walkers first showed up we lived in a
Motor Inn survived really awful [ __ ]
Lily tried to keep us all together looks
like she's changed yeah
seems that way damn there boy gunned
them down during an argument
Carly was her name she refused to let
Lily push her around he was right about
darling I haven't seen Lily sense I
believe you but there's something else
well he said someone was with you at the
gates James
he saved me an AJ what a stain is camp
for the night why did you bring him here
you led him right to us
I mean he's a stranger clumb running
into those two in the woods
it proved we can't trust anybody look
he's not with the Raiders he lives by
himself in the woods well he said he was
wearing I don't know animal skins or
something
yeah animal skin yeah wearing walker
skin
it's how he gets past herds he can guide
them to Wow
okay I wouldn't have brought him here if
I thought he was a threat it's not that
I don't trust you I'm just worried about
the others and what they might do they
didn't even get a chance to mourn Brodie
and Marlin before these child snatching
[ __ ] showed up and then you two come
back after we thought you were dead now
they're confused and no one knows how to
feel about AJ violet
AJ is the least of their worries I know
but everything is such a mess they're
scared and angry and they're looking for
someone to blame I mean they kicked you
out how am I supposed to make them
change their minds about you it was
decided five to three against you don't
have to let me convince them yeah we
haven't had a speech yet and we need
that speech you know I thought at least
we would get a stay but we'll do next he
said they'll get more people and guns
and come attack us take everyone here
how the hell would he know he's watched
them for a while they're at war with
another community they take people to
fight for them is that what happened to
mini and Sophie they turned them into
soldiers yeah it'll happen to us too if
we don't stop them and he didn't even
like killing walkers they're likely to
keep the fax machine you know just in
case you got a fax look at this place
it's a fortress with a little work we
could make this place really hard to
attack do you actually know how to do
that yeah I was part of a siege once in
a town called Richmond here don't ask me
to it though
all right so let's play in our defense
as you see here the gate your your guy
defending it strong walls we need to
make them hard to climb over
so the Raiders have to come in through
the gates we used to keep barbed wire in
the greenhouse yeah and then you need to
get it the courtyards pretty wide open
not a lot of cover we should flip the
picnic tables narrow down the pathways
through it so we'll know which way
they're coming at the very least it'll
give us protection if they get past
these walls this is where we should make
our stand
I need to pee am I in the front and then
there's the big center that's what she
said oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
keep watching Starck F great jokes
coming that path with traps we can pull
back here luring in our attackers I like
it that's a good idea actually well you
guys don't use the green house anymore
do you
no we used to then we lost someone up
there walkers over ran the place and
Marlon wouldn't let us go back safe zone
we need to get that barbed wire so they
can't climb the walls I'll go oh my god
are you sure it's gonna be swarming with
walkers by now okay what the hell's
going on Jesus really told me she was
back but I was like no way violet
wouldn't just go against what we all
decided alright I broke it back up would
you keep it down the little boys asleep
his fevers already go in down Clem he's
gonna be okay great
you quit just a llamar medicine - Mitch
those people who shot Louis they're
arming up to attack the school we need
Clem's help like hell we do for all we
know she's one of them
she's not if you saw their leaders boot
on Clem's neck do you know that these
Raiders all carry guns and they know how
to use them so whatever you think of me
and AJ deal with it or you're gonna end
up dead I'd rather take my chances
climbs going to the greenhouse to find
barbed wire and anything else she thinks
we need for the fight and you're going
to help her uh no I'm not yes you are
it's too dangerous for her to go by
herself and you're good in a fight I can
go to you know to keep the peace
[ __ ] vy since when do you do one they
got calls
since the guy no-one else step the [ __ ]
up these two will meet you at the gate
and you can head to the greenhouse once
I've explained the situation
see you there might be good you know
people they hate each other if they work
together
I'm so sorry little dude ha please be
okay
oh I I kind of like Jaden Smith now this
game has changed my opinion about him
needs to think it was just a spoiled
brat but he's got a heart
it's gonna be alright she said it
he was just shot like it's not that big
a deal
okay guess I didn't realize how long
it's been laundry and walkers let's go
in without weapons this ain't budgin yes
clearly was opening the other way
something useful well we need that
barbed wire there must be another way in
what if it was just a pole collectibles
can be found around the world yes found
it
yeah yeah we got to keep this wild-boar
not too many in these parts but they
were more common where I grew up I used
to hunt him with my old man when I was
little I make terrible noises when they
die I like it it'll look good on my wall
let me just put this in my back pocket
there that's right he went inside my
back pocket everyone cuz why would I
have a backpack am i right fellas
hmm I can't see [ __ ] well there's too
much condensation on the inside
condensation that's a big word for you
shut up
condensation that means your ass what do
you want oh nothing you're only here cuz
we're desperate you know so don't get
comfy if we survive these Raiders you
and I are gonna have words let's survive
first seems fair
alright I see an opening thank you game
nope nevermind are you okay
it's been so long since I was here how
you still love this place but it's so
overgrown I'll be fine
let's just find a way in how do you not
know our way in if you weren't here all
the time
I don't understand these people that
window I bet we can get in there good
spot MIT come here and give me a boost
wait make her go first yeah why we don't
mind losing oh nice a ugly thing to say
I'll go first
I don't mind figured you'd fight it
Thanks clam yeah that's the only reason
she's going right when grad C otherwise
we'll come as soon as you give the
all-clear I guess we'll know when the
door opens Oh
well you know I would probably Scout it
a little bit before jumping but you know
all right this is that big we actually
went in without a weapon it's two of
them we can handle them so this one is
faster well God he went the same way
[Applause]
heck yeah clam your rule that was awful
I'm coming I'll get the door open we
literally just survived because there
happened to be knife they're not bad oh
[Laughter]
look
Wow ginger she's talking about herself
booyah
Eastern prickly pear Jerusalem artichoke
false to home and seal let's find that
barbed wire and anything else that might
be useful I'm sick of talking to me but
let's just get there barbed wire
lawnmower that's awesome Clementine is
not impressed all right sorry Clementine
shovel that's epic
could be a weapon or you use it to dig a
grave you weren't there when we dug the
holes for Marlon and Brody we had to use
cups and bowls took forever yeah that's
kind of [ __ ]
it's pretty good just put that in my
back pocket just slide it in there for
locks okay so we this is another thing
with games like you find you'll find the
component that you need before you find
the obstacle
so awkward
[Applause]
maybe if we have something strong we can
use it to open barbed wire
a lot of it too as you keep the Rangers
from climbing our walls hey we can use
these we can just put them in there
buckler back pocket we can make bombs
out of these bombs are you serious
totally it's the kind of stuff I made
back home he used to blow [ __ ] up that's
why he's a troubled youth healthy let's
go let's need some propane and something
to create a spark and we'll have
ourselves a nice little homemade
explosive so far there lie surplus
propane equals bomb some mushrooms are
edible
probably not edible find something yep
maybe useful she has a really big back
pocket let me just say they eat the
mushroom why would I you seem happy
definitely the same bland rabbits do so
many times before you go crazy these
herbs are gonna do wonders for morale
you wait and see if I remember right
there's a science lab through that door
maybe there's propane in their car would
make sense help me move this thing
see now we're working as a team and
we're bonding look at that I love it
that's excellent
this is great for team morale this is
very slow isn't it look at that sure
okay let's see what's inside
Clemmy goes first G wedding it's a blind
zone me what oh you all right it's a
blind zone you had a scare
that's all what you know her
who was she miss Martin her nurse at the
school she stayed when all the others
left God she looks can barely recognize
her
she's just just like all the others
triple Don I just wish I could make her
look like she used to
one day we came out looking for food
walkers attacked us thought we could
fight him off but there were just her so
many MS Martin told us to run so we did
she taught me how to patch people up
stitch in local anesthetics painkillers
fever reducers I don't think I can
she's so smart to ye hear her would you
I'm sorry
sure I don't like these you got a little
bit of side boob action that nice are
you okay yeah
just need a minute come on gussy that's
the zombie you find that propane and we
can get out of here
find bomb components what were they
doing
making silver Hey look I thought it's
hope there's gas in it it's so awkward
I'm pressing really fast yeah perfect
here good find
we got the propane now if we could just
find something to create a spark like a
lighter you guys don't have those
something to create a spark
look
looks like piss dear let me drink it not
the million years wind oh my god they're
totally bonding an igniter Mitch is this
useful
[ __ ] hey let's open there be one of
those that's an igniter we can use it to
create a spark it's the last thing we
need to blast those [ __ ] to
hell we should get back and tell the
others language not until we bury Miss
Martin be her your why bother
it's a walker help me drag it out back
we can burn it nope
Ms Martens the reason we're all alive
and she deserves a proper burial here
next to the greenhouse she loved the
others won't have to see her like this
she's been dead for years
there's no point I'll help you bury her
it's the right thing to do for someone
you cared about thank you so much it's
not her it's a walker
fine whatever I'm not wasting my energy
on that thing
I'll put a stone in the graveyard back
at the school but Ms Martin loved this
place she'll be happy here I'll make
sure everyone knows you helped me hey
you've got a good heart under all that
look hey sorry I can't awkwardly giggle
- Wow it it takes a long time to dig a
grave like I don't know it'll be enough
you know whenever hopefully it means
Lily and her people won't be able to
climb the walls oh there's no way she
could carry come on straight into a
fiery explosion of death [ __ ] won't
know what hit them
like us heavy stuff okay I'm just trying
to be factually correct here guys I'm
the fact god no wait I'm not that's
Michael McCrone and Who am I kidding
looks like AJ can teleport huh
brought you these I noticed his shirt
got messed up when you know where did
you get those
they were tens back when he got here
should be about a J sighs how's he doing
better his fevers down thank you for
carrying him in no problem so we've got
a greenhouse again
and bombs Mitch's idea I figured violet
says we'll start getting this place
ready in the morning
fertilizing bomb fertilizers come used
to farm crop can feed an explosion under
the right circumstances maybe I
shouldn't be googling these kind of
stuff all right
geesh they all seemed okay with letting
you stay for now anyway
while we get ready to fight yeah I'm
glad all I've wanted is for them to
forgive us I said they're fine with you
being here at least until the Raiders
are gone
that doesn't mean they own like you
again everyone else is okay with a sting
what about you it's fine well he gets
better and after that I don't know
Clementine Clem hey kiddo
how do you feel better still hurts I
know huh hey little dude I missed you
how are you friends again just get some
sleep okay Lois I'm sorry that you're
hurting and it's our fault it wasn't oh
you Marlon he he done he done messed up
forget it
I should go I wonder if he ever takes a
jacket off
do you think he sleeps with it I'm not
mad at him anymore
are you yeah would you kill this you
just say he was by my book when he gave
me stuff AJ I was never mad at him I
understand why he acted that way why he
wanted us gone huh me too
let's get a look at the shirts Luis
brought you then we'll sleep it's been a
long day yeah
James was nice but I don't like sleeping
on the ground me neither
let's get you a new sweating which one
do you want this one I don't get to pick
there's a disco broccoli shirt and I
don't get to pick it this is ridiculous
this is the problem this is why no you
know what never mind
hey all right
I get to pick I was wrong I'm so sorry
disco broccoli disco brought me I wish
you could have seen this cartoon me too
me too
hey yes yes I'm sorry that they loves
wrong you can put it on when you feel
better okay yeah time for sleep I can't
sleep with a light I'll blow it out in a
second
change the sweater change the goddamn
sweater got it right to sleep tight
don't wait bye and if it tries some
fries okay alright Clementine didn't
like that
oh I see that's why Oh
so we're preparing for an attack this
episode oh it's a nightmare
no we were up all night
No
what in the world is happening oh it's
been a while
I'm sorry but this is really awkward
okay is he just sleeping all the time
[Music]
I thought they would attack way sooner
now it's a nightmare
what in the world hey Jay
where are you
I don't think we're in a nightmare at
all I think it will definitely be real
what is the borders represent
what is to me is that the s they did the
s the legendary s there in it
do you see it I'm sorry I know there's a
horse and all but it did you guys see
the s sorry can we go back to the s hey
you can be hit
[Music]
come on no no yeast I'm gonna beat you I
don't care I'm gonna beat you it's
meeting time yeah
AJ
[Music]
oh this is that I see we see me
what the heck are you doing on the table
if he's not wearing sorry I don't mean
to break the mood if he is not wearing
the broccoli t-shirt then I am done
alright I'm quitting this episode right
now I'm not finishing it I'm 100%
serious same when you used to have all
the time about what happened at the
ranch I'll be okay just give me a minute
Jesus Christ I knew you're freaky as
hell hey what do you have there
did you have a bad dream too
you've been having them a lot lately we
now I don't like this not sleeping I
want to stay up forever I probably could
like 18 days if I try it hard I've never
seen that knife before did you make it
when I don't know while you were busy it
must have taken days I couldn't stop
thinking about it until I made it
here let me help you back to bed no you
don't have to keep checking on me
you always say be tough so I am you say
be strong and I will all the time I
raised you to be strong not stupid I'm
not shutting people out when they're
trying to help you that's stupid
please don't call me stupid I mean they
don't act it's stupid I'm sorry you had
to do all the hard work to a Tony I'm
gonna help you boy so you don't
understand anything
where are you going on patrol patrol for
danger bad people monsters whatever you
have nightmares about absolutely not
it's dark out there
um actually um gonna tired I'd uh kind
of rather stay yeah I figured what is it
can I could I maybe sleep in your bed
like I did when I was little yeah come
on up
I'm not scared just tired make sense to
me
think you need that
AJ what
you're still little ya know do you think
it's in our natural morale or like DNA -
that makes no sense
but to have the idea some weather is
right to kill or not cuz surely that
just comes natural it seems like he's
been brought up with the idea to just
kill danger but he doesn't even think
about what he means to kill in our the
human but that just doesn't make any
sense ready to work today kiddo
bad dreams always make me more tired me
too I slept better in your bed it's my
turn to be lookout
I have other stuff I need to do that's
stuff nothing it's just it's important
god damn it seriously who wants a new
life I've been taking this seriously for
[ __ ] days almost two weeks so has
everyone get over yourself
why does it sound like she's far away
cool I'm glad everyone's having a great
time I thought Lilly and Abel would show
up days ago I wonder why they're holding
off don't know all I wanted was more
time to prepare but now this waiting
sucks and everything we don't know
anything about the enemy can we at least
spy on them or anything yeah actually
could you check on everyone and make
sure they're doing [ __ ] right sure I'm
on it
thanks Clem I should go board up the
back hallway since Lois isn't gonna do
it
go away II see this game doesn't like
easy there I like that go away you're
dead meme II all right Louis what's up
oh I thought he just shot that huh
mm-hmm that's shareable what's going on
in a few weeks or days or hours the
Raiders will be here burn down our place
and steal or kill us and they don't
matter how much I sucked at this the
Raiders aren't gonna burn anything or
steal anybody we'll stop it you sound
like Marlon I mean not about fighting
but when he was trying to cheer us all
up for years i sat around making stupid
jokes playing stupid games while my best
friend was left with all the
responsibility all the tough calls all
the sleepless nights and eventually a
bullet in the head and I didn't do a
damn thing about it
and then when you tried to tell us what
he was really like and AJ shot him I
blamed you both of you if I could take
it back I would
I knew that the day you got back I still
do I forgive you I understand why you
did it I'm not angry he was my best
friend almost like my brother but the
things he did they were [ __ ] up here
you take it yeah probably a lot better I
mean it's
Marlon's yeah it was and he used it to
defend the school before before he
stopped go ahead try it in that
direction please now coming from you all
right Jaden Smith I'll show you how it's
done and just so you know I'm totally
laughing out loud when you miss coming
from him it will mean anything wow this
is really hard
Wow I can't believe you were so bad at
this
damn remind me to never piss you off
while I'm standing at a moderate
distance with a big red circle painted
on my chest you want to come back and
practice more just let me know I don't
think any of you practice okay I am
sorry I don't think I need practice and
Clem thank you
for all of it alright Affleck
freckle-faced don't mention it buddy you
practice shooting with Lewis alright
okay that's cool let's check on the kids
I like how they keep these around I
probably do the same oh that's missing
you know climb you nice do you think
Sophie and mini might be with him when
they get here I don't know maybe
I'm doing watching fun for danger like
patrol no clan lookouts totally
different than patrol how so
you don't walk oh right let's get some
genius and skits a goddamn mastermind
let's look at the pile of heads
I like it you know normally you would
put them outside of your defenses to
scare people off and not inside your
home hey Mitch what's up hey what are
you doing with the bombs yeah gotta see
if the bomb will go off just this little
thing won't kill anybody just gotta see
if it'll light ya head better the whole
plan rests on that little thing if they
get in I'll need you to set the bomb off
while I distract them expect the
unexpected
yeah something like that I read that I'm
one of those stupid inspirational
posters school used to have them
everywhere as soon as things went to
[ __ ] I came all down
epic stupid [ __ ] could you my hands all
[ __ ] up for messing with it all day
[ __ ] stop [ __ ] swearing jesus
[ __ ] christ
run it run clementine [ __ ] [ __ ] well
it doesn't work I'm sure you'll get it
keep trying it's not like I got all the
time in the world the places I kiss and
figure this [ __ ] out I'll figure people
friend Texas more time you're now alone
time to think I get it
I'll leave you alone thanks though for
helping
you help Mitch with his bomb chicken
would violate okay let's do it guys
let's go check hey violet what's up back
hallways secure how is everyone
okay or you know a total [ __ ] mess
well honestly it's not perfect but
they're trying they're doing everything
they can
trying isn't gonna stop them from
getting kidnapped trying isn't going to
stop these Raiders from burning down our
[ __ ] home they stopped giving out
participation trophies when walkers
started eating people all right Tim
certain look-alike persons
I'm being stupid you're the one who
can't think straight if you could hear
yourself guys what the [ __ ] violet told
us to work on the traps together but a
sim won't listen to anything I say
doesn't mean you have to scream at each
other stay out of this I have an idea
for duffle bags filled with bricks we
drop them on the Raiders if they get to
the admin building Willy here wants to
use a giant idiotic swinging log to take
out one Raider at most it's completely
stupid you're stupid you're being
childish
I'm trying to help so help I don't know
I need to look at Barnes Ewing III don't
care going with the Simms plan what but
nothing it's more practical why it's
practical too no it isn't it's exactly
the kind of thing a child would think of
especially a child who has no idea what
he's up against oh dude you okay yeah
fine
[ __ ] well I'll kill each other before
the Raiders even get a [ __ ] chance
what we need is something to break the
tension
a scissor hey buddy how's it hanging
dude [ __ ] off something on the corner
isn't gonna help us fight off the
Raiders or turn that frown upside down
you get more annoying every day
regardless I've come up with a plan to
make everybody feel better and that plan
is a game come on we got a play okay
y'all do you can it happen which is also
we played a game in weeks
oh we got a night at it I know where I
mean if you want to go ask Ruby to come
play I don't need to connect dude you've
got a crush on Ruby what do we play
truth or dare you know use cards and
truth or dare you do in this version
everyone draws highs card gets to ask
Lois card has to answer well I saw an
ace at the bottom so we should just pick
that heck you guys we got on it Wow ah
this should be good let's see truth
marry [ __ ] killed by fine marry flip
kill Ruby a sim or James that guy who
saved oh my god you gotta answer
them's the rules James and when he west
Szymanski I would marry
James he sounds mysterious
funny you pronounce horrifying
differently than I do
didn't you say he wore skin like human
skin yeah is you happy Clem I would um
flip flip flip flip flip flip flip flip
hey Dave hey Dave no
Ruby sorry I was just imagining her
glare while Clinton propositions her
what you sure that's a good idea what's
wrong with you
she picked Ruby gets a flip so that
means you're killing this is amazing
assume Oh God ha ha ha
you'd rather die than marry her flip
Clem I know I didn't mean it like that
this is great we're laughing we're
bonding today break from thinking about
homicidal [ __ ] sneaking into our
homes to kidnap us not if you bring it
up on to round 2 there's thingies at the
bottom there's the A's at the bottom
claims get the A's win and poor sim
loses definitely a dare okay do your
worst
shame that stupid go kiss that Walker
head what
you have to kiss a walker what no way
gotta play by the rules my dude that's
like I could die avoid the teeth go for
the cheek Oh gross watch mojo top 10
romances that was amazing
well I think we all learned something
about our good friend Asim today mainly
that he has no romantic charm what so a
shot-up and as one likes to bully it's
time for round three AJ's gonna lose
I got it we've been pretty hard on poor
assim here teasing him about sweet ruby
seems only fair we mercilessly tease
someone else about unrequited love
so Clem anyone here you like like
seriously like like what are you six
I've made a lot of friends here but I'm
not sure I have a crush on anyone there
you go Lois nothing cuz these are about
oh there's so plenty to tease her about
the Hat for what
don't she gets really mad oh oh there's
a set the bottom Klan pull the ACE ah
Sam you've got the high card and the
loser is technique J Oh what's something
you've never told anyone because you
were afraid they'd make fun of you you
got this I I think I think Walker's
won't always be around so go away
someday because the world goes in cycles
right ice age Stone Age um some other
ages so it's like a genius Harlan wants
another location and another one will
start an age without walkers like it
used to be
it'll be better
why is everyone looking at me like that
did I ruin the game that's really
beautiful I never thought of it that way
what's wrong aging I just don't know
what it's like all of you do but I don't
I don't remember a time before monsters
you know what salud it's okay that you
don't thank you everyone the internet
world before this one was pretty shitty
that's how I talk about the Internet and
that feels like a good place to call it
we should finish up our work anyway it's
getting dark you're on Lookout yep
clementines got it after me can I come
of course you can little guy she reminds
me of a Harry Potter character I don't
know which one then
Hey
hey why don't we do it maybe you want to
help me with the brick trap yeah I got
some ideas cool
I'm sure they'll help sorry I punched
you it's okay it's a pretty good punch
almost got my penis I'm headed to the
bell tower I want to check out our
defenses on the back wall before bed do
you need help
sure if you want you could always help
me instead I'm on piano duty what I got
to get in some practice before one of
you decides to chop it into firewood
I've got a project I want to try but I
need a second person
[Music]
sorry but I don't think now it's time
for piano that's just my my law thing
all right
I think we're heading towards the end
and the game looks like it's got some
issues
oh no oh we're fine we're fine we're
fine everybody
[Music]
this is really creepy so we're checking
the walls yep
sorry I gotta pee to go home I see you
ready first reminds me last time we were
in a clock tower the PewDiePie
look-alike dying looks a little
dangerous what's more dangerous than
walkers or that death trap you called a
car okay
fair come on you're not chicken right
you're gonna thank you about chicken
nuggets
not really I do they always back them on
Sundays there's no time for grandma to
cook between church and Bible studies so
fast food given eyeball for a chicken
nugget really and yes only if it comes
with a dip remember when McDonald's used
to have the hot chili sauce the hot
chili dip for the Nuggets mm-hmm
Albert that was good times my college is
so gross now I don't know what they
chamber sends they try to become healthy
it's like no you're ruining it the
elimar core remember they'll mock aw oh
my god you put it in the bag and you
shake it with the spice barbed wire
traps weapons it's everything we planned
you made it happen we couldn't have done
it without you
you've got Lookout duty tonight right
yep me and AJ
do you have time to hang out first no
sure
that's an awesome Tower
a great overlook
that's awesome
Wow beautiful
sometimes I need the quiet just to get
away for a while
it's this ship sailing is this huh yeah
you know he came back for medicine for
AJ but after that you could have just
left avoided all the [ __ ] with the
Raiders why didn't you sorry I know that
puts you on the spot you don't have to
answer where you are EJ and I are safer
here Lilly and Abel proved that yeah
that's true
until they get here anyway do you know
any constellations nope you I learned
some in school but I can't remember them
let's make some up I'm over here you can
sit down with that blowing through dad
that's nice okay I'll see if I remember
right everyone's born under a special
sign right it determines your
personality
that's astrology not astronomy okay
let's just make up our own rules signs
what it says about you if this is life
it's really they would have some weird
indie music like right now there see
it's a [ __ ] some OC TV show type of
music
you know this constellation you know
about this one
you haven't heard about this one yeah
you haven't heard about this one okay
oh yeah yeah fish no it needs a
personality right you guys good with
other please always moving tons of
energy
sounds like anyone we know the energy
one is easy good with people not so much
that's AJ wherever I look there he is
taking up all my attention and I love
him for it it's getting better around
other people you're doing good with him
yeah except been killing people apart I
spy with my see it hmm
right there right above your head yeah
they're all above my head Bing bong Bing
bong bong bing bang boom Bow Wow Wow
friend right that's not a nice
successful smart clean vicious
dependable someone you want with you in
a fight doesn't take crap from anyone
gets [ __ ] done
that's each one sounds like AJ I know
okay one more time I found a bird like a
real bird geez that right there all
right let me just connect them Hey
gameplay everybody boom boom boom I want
you in my room
it's been that night - yeah
which one do you want from me ya dingus
a bird is free it could go anywhere it
wanted to up and up and up and never
come back
those south east west doesn't matter
it's all of us everyone here wishes they
could fly away from all of this maybe
you will learn to fly together someday
sorry I didn't mean to dis talk so much
if it was me I would focus more on this
part and just cut the card game part
because I feel like we already had a
downtown bit and this just seems kind of
redundant thank you even though it's a
nice moment but you did and now I can't
imagine what it would be like if you
weren't here it's this bad pacing that
sounds much dumber when I say though
we're friends good ones
it's good to have a friend again someone
I can really trust
so do we gotta like make friendship
bracelets or something I really do
I hate arts and crafts [ __ ] sticks
probably time for your lookout shift
ready yeah so did I pick her over Jaden
Smith and that could have been a romance
with Jaden Smith did I just mess up
everything I think so oh well
[Music]
this could be the last few moments
during a walk and then I feel like I
need to cherish it more he's gonna be
with them Abel
yeah I wonder if James will come to the
rescue your bad dreams they're all about
him aren't they yeah can that's where
yet I think it's time I can know come on
kiddo quit asking because I would swear
about his stupid face yeah
try thinking about something else count
the monsters you see same numbers before
three for AJ it's okay if Abel frightens
you
you know how to control that there's ten
monsters out there
he doesn't frighten me but when he comes
here I call dibs I'm the one that kills
him she says okay
hey J I don't like the way you're
talking killing is never easy or fun or
to be treated so casually is it because
I'm trying to be good because of Marlon
it's just because you should never think
about killing like that agent must be so
confused seems so lost in this one
there's 12 of them now
well what if we played Rock Paper
Scissors if I win you change your mind
and I get dibs on Abel I can take him
Clem please I'm not being casual fine
whatever I don't care
yeah okay really best two out of three
sucker and no take-backs no take-backs
second get ready one
- hey we're always win paper
got'em tide go again again alright we
hit them with this psychology they think
we're gonna pick paper again so we're
gonna hit scissors scissors bottom
goddamn works every time you dumb ball
you dumb you stupid no one - and now
back to paper
what again one two sister again they'll
never expect them scissors
suck it stuck in a J you suck
you useless you try get a D ok ok
Clinton why don't they just pick them up
when they're asleep
here you look - that's Rick James oh
yeah we need to a flank they're going in
yeah okay I get it
that's not a walker
good job EJ come on we have to tell the
others
they finally show up
yeah how do they know stay safe okay
we're ready
they've got at least four more people
all carrying guns and carts probably to
carry people away no [ __ ] I can't
believe they're really here if they get
inside I'll keep them focused on me that
should give Willy and Mitch time to set
up the bomb I'll set it under those
carts it'll work I promise if they
manage to get in we fall back to the
admin building exactly right into our
traps they're in for a rude [ __ ]
surprise those duffel bags will break
bones easy so I'm excited any final
words of wisdom in everyone after all
your life sort of trying to die
Oh Go Go I'll be all right
yeah just hide go all right shift queue
everybody oh yeah everyone knows tables
all right I'll take the fire bullet oh
no it's the m14 game this bad shoot the
horse it's okay just try not to move or
make noise
should be able to be all this somebody
said the bomb come on spread out the ass
how do they not see her secondly I'll
shoot you won't get the chance they have
people where's our new recruits they're
not yours search the yard what's the
plan here climbing
if Clementine moves shooter
set up the bomb
we'll find them Clementine and then
we'll take them and you take me you want
soldiers fine take me with you but leave
everyone else you do that you'd come
with me if I let the others go yes
you've changed I grew up I can see that
God you are just like him we would have
been heartbroken knowing he taught you
all the wrong things that the sweet
little girl he protected turned out like
this
here right Lily I am just like him and
if he saw me now he'd be proud of Who I
am why because you almost gave up just
now handed yourself over to save your
friends right I'm sure that made all his
sacrifice is worth it
get out if you won't help me find the
others I'll find someone who will we
recruited from this school before Minny
wanted to come along tonight to tell you
how well she's adjusted to her life how
happy she is she said she had a
girlfriend back here friends she missed
one guy who could always make her laugh
no matter what and her little brother
she missed him the most no [ __ ]
where are they let me take you to them I
can't I just want them back please shut
up
Lily you've always been a liar and a
killer you're not taking anyone else for
me no yeah almost got it
yeah shoot her in the face
shoot her why didn't you shoot oh my god
you're so dumb
[Music]
shoot her
yes all you can aim at yes oh oh oh oh
that's Oh
no I'm shooting for the head thank you
what is this what is this stupid thing
they just stabbed a kid in the head okay
I'm not aiming for the layers that's
ridiculous
and even slow him down he says as fast
as the other all right well we have the
traps that will break bones a guy is
about it's not like we couldn't have
killed him before killed that one a girl
[Applause]
shooting our town
now shoot in the head shoot in a pocket
pointless I told Lily you would
cooperate
it doesn't make million around this time
so we'll have a nice little chat you and
me alone
on your merits I would just go for it I
would kill them right away weak small
afraid and still alive well let a lot of
folks die to get you here that one hurts
now AJ killed now you can go come on
Alexa
come on Baldy
what you got Baldy finish him No
damn that sucks oh well no he broke his
legs this should be easy
then do it already shoot me you're
betting I don't care just get it over
with
Shirley yeah I know everything about in
the combat all right so I'm getting real
sick of people
[Music]
shoot shoot them
favor later okay I have to make a quick
choice
I just might and he's I like him that's
right everybody I like Jaden
oh my god
oh the villain their billing shot
all right at same time
Oh what
damn
what in the world just happened
damn sell everything to get at that what
a gun nevermind
all right there's what is a beach but
Clemens games got a lot of ammo friends
thanks for killing them aging
[Music]
clam
I'm sorry for trusting her yeah you
messed up
yeah that was mess-up
God Asim Omar
they're just gone and violet
I never thought someone would get her
we're going after them how we still
don't know where they are or how many
well we have some guns we've got someone
who does Oh
[Music]
oh yeah
Wow wah-wah-wah oh wow okay okay AJ was
sorry let me turn on the volume AJ okay
all right
rip Endon and kidnapped all right okay
uh-huh and trusted okay all right okay
grateful okay and dead know I shamed
captured saved guilt ridden unconvinced
she looks so different
Danya poor Mitch
oh I missed the plant damn I messed up
guys I'll do better next time today that
was really fun I enjoyed this episode
more than Episode one but I think that's
natural because episode one is always
gonna be the setup right but that's also
what's so annoying if there's always a
setup to this games it's like why can't
we just play in what they have there's
such an emotional attachment between Lee
and Clementine even though Lee this is
not even alive but for any of the other
characters it's just like I guess it
will pick Jaden and we're violent this
could possibly be the last episode we
play I we don't know whether they're
gonna release episode three or four him
allegedly on November 6 I'll let you
guys know if it comes out I'll be
playing it if it does if it doesn't kind
of a sad ending to end it like this I'd
be crazy that'd be crazy but you know a
lot of people are talking about it house
another company could buy the rights for
it but it's a lot more complicated than
that you have different people owning
different parts of it and it might seem
easy from over an outsider a lot of
these things like oh yeah can't we just
do a Kickstarter oh yeah can't we just
do this and I think it's cool that
people want to help but it's always way
more complicated than you think and all
the legal stuff is always just crazy
especially when it comes to video games
so we can only hope we get to see the
conclusion of Clementine but yeah thanks
for watching this episode regardless it
was fun I it's a shame that they're
picking up on these things now it sucks
to be honest but I hope you had fun
watching anyway look like if you did I
appreciate all the support I saw always
thank you guys so much for watching and
I'll see you tomorrow with another video
goodbye
you